hi kids welcome back here is what we're
going to do step 1 we're actually going
to analyze the file name itself and
determine what file type it is by
looking at the extension of the file
name this function is going to return an
integer which represents what type of
file it is for our purposes we've
defined that 0 should be an image and
type 1 should be a JavaScript file now
as you can see loading a javascript file
is very similar to loading an image we
actually create the object we set a
callback and then we actually set its
source now there's a couple other things
we have to do because we're injecting
script into the Dom like setting its
attribute type and then actually
appending it to the dump but other than
those two things it's pretty similar the
real magic comes down here at the bottom
when we actually analyze the filename to
determine what type it is so for example
it if it has a dot jpg we assume it's an
image versus ajs which we assume is then
JavaScript